une année 2021 sous le signe du ras le
bol à paris à toulouse ou encore à lyon
les manifestations se multiplient avec
des slogans des plus explicites
c'est la jeunesse qui prend un très gros
coup de cette crise sanitaire
cette crise économique ça c'est sûr et
en plus les attaques du gouvernement sur
différents plans que ce soit vis-à-vis
de l'emploi que ce soit vis-à-vis de
l'enseignement elle se dirige d'abord
vers les jeunes
c'est une génération qui est sacrifiée
parce que ça vous sur tous les domaines
en fait il ya l'augmentation des loyers
crouzillat plus la possibilité pour nous
d'avoir un tueur d'étudiants et que à
côté et c'était donc ça ça augmente la
capacité économique des étudiants à bien
vivre une situation préoccupante qui se
résume en quelques chiffres éloquents
selon un dernier sondage ipsos deux
jeunes sur trois estiment que la crise
actuelle liés à la coved 19 va avoir des
conséquences négatives sur leur propre
santé mentale toujours selon cette
enquête trois jeunes sur dix ont pensé à
se donner la mort ou à se mutiler une
dépression liés aux nombreux changements
d'emploi du temps à l'isolément ou
encore à l'incertitude face à l'avenir
j'ai été accueillis aux urgences et epci
à la suite d'une grosse crise angoisse
j'avais jamais eu d'épisode d'angoise
comme ça et ça a été le cas
le premier jour où je devais me lever
pour aller à l'école parmi tous les
étudiants en france y est vraiment
prenante de la un peu de déprime de
beaucoup d'isolement et c'est vrai que
j'ai pu avoir de l' angoisse par rapport
à l'avenir par rapport à comment on va
s'en sortir même si on avait toujours de
l'espoir
ce qui me pèse le plus c'est du coup
dans l'incompréhension qu'on ne parle
pas directement
on a vraiment le sentiment d'être
oubliés
je pense au hashtag des étudiants
fantômes pour tenter de reprendre la
main
le gouvernement multiplie les
interventions auprès des jeunes comme
avec cette émission mensuelle diffusée
sur plusieurs plateformes vidéo est
intitulée sans filtre pour sa première
le porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent a invité mercredi dernier
plusieurs jeunes influenceurs très
suivie par ce public à venir débattre
sur la situation précaire des étudiants
un casting qui n'a pas tardé à faire
réagir sur les réseaux sociaux une honte
absolue d'inviter des personnes qui ne
sont pas concernés pour parler de la
détresse étudiantes ont fait des études
pour gagner notre vie tandis que les
influenceurs gagne déjà bien là leur
grâce au réseau et sponsors ils ne nous
représentent en aucun cas si vous voulez
donner la parole à des étudiants petit
conseil
invité des étudiants montré du doigt
pour ses interventions gabriela talent
refuse le terme de génération sacrifiée
et préfère mettre en avant le plan un
jeune une solution mis en place cet été
est doté d'une enveloppe de 6,5
milliards d'euros
le porte parole du gouvernement évoque
aussi le dispositif un repas un euro
adopté par plusieurs restos
universitaires les crous mais vivement
critiquées pour leur faible qualité
nutritive
malgré ces différentes initiatives 14
syndicats étudiants et mouvements de
jeunes appellent à se mobiliser dans
toute la france pour leur avenir
le 16 mars prochain